what do you make of the defense that
pardon is facing so far from the Raptors
well you can see tried to kick it out
and Leonard with those hands got his
hands on it
he finishes hit the other end the
Raptors all waiting for it and the
fast-break gets around ciacco
passes
for reading day the read will be a great
addition to that second unit for the
Rockets adding a little bit more depth
18 point lead
collide it's the deep three torques it
kind of blows me away how seamlessly and
quickly as harden gets the floater to
fall up to 15 very very strong Leonard
strong as well he put harden pardon me
for read in the weight room on that play
nurse talks about him being a great new
guys Harden right over the top of green
like he wasn't there ready clears mr.
Rockets leading by 10
pardon inside the wrong foot layup is
good
rather smaller but he's working right
now I do think he's done incredible jobs
James Hart gets another floater to go he
makes that difficult shot look easy not
impacted the other aspects of what he
does but he doesn't look right another
floater at the payment another bucket
for James Hart Leonard with a nice base
on Tucker who didn't bite
Leonard that those huge hands held it
like a grapefruit tourists like a bad
man Hannibal because he plays so hard
puts it up and played almost made him
change his shot they get buried last
year at this time when they needed a
productive body that was just kind of
hanging around he was jailed green as
blind Leonard gets the layup to go in
soft noise you got to do everything to
make sure that that's going to occur and
if you play in June there's no way you
can be impressed by that there's another
three-pointer by